making his fifth start of the year won
his first three starts before hung with
a loss against the brewers last weekend
his right-hander sonny gray i just love
watching the skype it'll be adam frazier
to lead things off here's a 3-2 in a
swing and a miss since sunny gray picks
up a strikeout
against adam frazier kevin newman one
hit in five at bats last night
and a two-hopper to galvez he'll have to
cut it loose and does in time newman can
get up that line and two quick outs for
sonny gray
here's chad cool facing sonny gray and
akiyama oh for three last night it's
amazing there's a ground ball backhanded
by newman behind the bag throws on and
gets in a nice stretch by bell on the
other end well done so went out nick
castiano's swine from cool and the pitch
to castillanos and a swing and a miss
struck him out two away
joey vado choke it up he only allowed
six hits and now nine and two thirds
innings 13 strikeouts and he gets
another
swing and a miss a half-hearted swing by
vato for the strikeout we've played one
pirates nothing red's nothing
brian reynolds a second round pick out
of vandy
and that strike three call a fastball
center cut and the second strikeout for
sonny gray
now gregory polanco
and that's on the outside corner again
with a fastball perfect location
or he is pinpointing his fastball
tonight jesse winker four-game hitting
streak nine for his last 13.
in the air left field hit pretty well
and winker has done it again and he is
sprinting around those bases tonight
he might set a record
that's a home run in four of the last
five games for jesse winker man is he
hot ray going to work against jacob
stallings payoff pitch and he will get
it
yeah i was chasing ball for stallings
and just looked too good to him harbor
winds up at third base 3-2 pitch there's
a swing and a miss he struck him out
with a runner in third
and now two outs that's number five
chad cool brian reynolds struck out
looking his first time up
and now a drive to right field hit deep
going back toward the wall and anchor
down brian reynolds
it's his first home run of the season
off of fellow commodore
and it is 1-1 in the fourth
struck out his first time up
that's a bullet off the vat of vato into
right center and that'll have cool
fuming even more because he thought he
had him struck out high reds after the
pirates tied on the reynolds home run at
the top of this inning trying to get
right back in front after a two-base hit
from vato
and in the air to right field and dewink
is on
fire i tell you what i i don't know if
i've seen a guy this hot in a long long
time he is absolutely blistering
everything off that back i mean totally
locked
and the reds are back on top it's three
to one gonzales he has one of the two
hits tonight against sunny gray
here's another strikeout make it seven
for sonny gray here's bell represents a
tying run here in the top of the sixth
inning
pickup
sliding uh van meter to his left
on to second goes newman one out in the
inning that's a big play
on the third base goes newman two outs
in the inning yo two to reynolds
that's all she wrote okay he tried
calling time and it was too late
that'll bring to the play eric gonzalez
no bowl two-strike count
swing and a miss there's that slider
down and away and
gray made that picture perfect for his
10th strikeout of the night
nate jones in the game gray through 110
pitches one short of his reds
career high
[Applause]
there's a laser into left field and
again it is showgo he did it twice last
night
and does it again tonight
and that one could prove to be a game
saver so the reds with a little
something cooking here in the seventh
leading three to one trying to add to it
here one another count to barnhart
[Applause]
one hop diving play they get one
and barnard's safe at first base scoring
his van meter so a fielder's choice rbi
for tucker and the reds make it a four
to one game and now a chance for
castellanos with two on and two out
that'll back up tucker to the track to
the wall
and he tries to get it goodbye
that ball continued to carry
tucker kept backing up on it
and castellanos a three run big fly to
break this one wide open
and it is now seven to one red brandon
waddell takes the big league mound for
the first time
and he strikes out jesse winker looking
tucker barnhart hits now with galvez at
second
[Applause]
lined hard into right off the bat of
tucker barnard
and that'll be a run-scoring double for
tucker
and the reds have tacked on another run
it's eight to one two men are out
gregory polanco the last hope for the
pirates tonight
on the ground short right field
long throw and they got him an absolute
ball game van meter made some nice plays
out there tonight he did a good job at
this one belongs to the reds